welcome back to unfiltered he's blown up
cars with tanks and almost bought george
washington's suit and listen i wouldn't
stand a chance negotiating a deal with
him on tv but like every other business
owner he's dealing with challenges too
like inflation one of my favorite shows
pawn star's very own rick harrison joins
me rick thank you so much for taking the
time i really appreciate you coming in
today
well thanks for having me
so rick i i've watched your show
religiously i don't think i've ever
missed an episode you buy and sell
assets all the time i mean it's
literally your livelihood a lot of them
on slim margins that's why you have to
become that good of a negotiator has
this inflation creeped into your shop i
mean you know comic books gold assets
how is it working for you
oh everything i mean i can't get
inventory um i mean it's so bad you walk
into a rolex store in las vegas in the
mall they have no rolexes i mean
everyone is just so afraid of the prices
going up more you know it's a snowball
effect and um you know when the
government just keeps on printing money
printing money it's just kind of basic
economics you're going to have a lot of
inflation
yeah yeah i mean i i i collect these
rare comic books and i buy gold bars too
and uh the prices are through the roof
uh rick quick follow-up for you here
listen i'm a hoarder i'm kind of
embarrassed to say i throw nothing out i
think i have my report card from second
grade um
i'm not sure that's worth any money in
your shop rick but any tips for us
newbies here on if something around the
house is valuable or just some
counterfeit piece of junk i mean you
know right away i watch your show you
seem to know or you have experts who
know pretty quick
i mean well first off we all have like
that uh information box you know it's
called the internet yeah do a lot of
research and uh
as far as telling if stuff is fake or uh
real and fake you know just you know if
you got a rolex or just about anything
like that it's amazing quality if it's
not it's probably fake
yeah it's a golden rule of thumb right
if it if it looks like crap it's
probably crap is that is that can i just
is that the rick harrison rule
generally that's the generally that's
the case but uh in some cases um it's
the complete opposite
hey rick thanks a lot for your time i
really appreciate you coming on today
love the show you guys do a great job
thank you
all right thanks for having me bud
bye-bye you got it hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else